i think you might be a bad influence on
each other
[Music]
hello june hello jennifer
i've recorded some questions here
and i've left enough space for you to
answer
[Music]
what do you think of your new school
which do you like better
sunshine or rain
how was your day girls
you spoke to me and then it was just
less and less you know
if there's something you want to
communicate
you best say it now
[Music]
jennifer
would you describe your personalities i
think you might be a bad influence on
each other it might be an idea to split
you up for a while
we will move the girls into special
education i want to say anything we'll
get them to talk yet guilty or not
guilty you need to take care of it
because please say something
how do you plead
they shall be institutionalized
indefinitely
[Applause]
if you were telling your story
how would it begin
in order to try out a good book you need
to feel it have to be inspired
[Music]
i can't bear life without my sister
it's brought a new awakening in me i
could reach out and touch the stars i
could see the galaxy i can't go back to
the empty days before we finally feel as
though i'm swimming in a pool i taste
the bittersweet smell of salt
it's like god gave me a chance to get
a challenge to prove who i really am
you